all right creatures of the internet it's
friday and that means it's time for
another roundtable table extravaganza
i'm still dave rubin this is the reuben
report and joining me today is the host
of the liz wheeler show liz wheeler the
host of jedediah bila live on
valuetainment tv jedediah bila and
former new york city police officer and
conservative commentator john cardillo
liz jedidiah john welcome to the reuben
report
good to see you dave
hi dave good to see you guys it was a
little chaos around here before we
started so sorry for the
little delay there i got a lot going on
in the house at the moment uh we are
going to talk about uh this joe biden
fella because it is not going well and
the media is starting to realize it
ain't going well uh but as you guys all
know there are things there are some
markers actually that there's ways to
turn this thing around that's going to
be the focus of the show today and
before we get to that let me talk to you
guys about real estate agents i trust
real quick you know buying or selling a
home is already one of the most
stressful things you can do and it can
be 10 times worse if you're not working
with the right agent generally speaking
our homes are our biggest investment i
know it is for me and that's a lot of
responsibility so you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the intro and
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost everywhere you want to go
including the free state of florida the
process is simple just go to real estate
agentsidetrust.com
and provide them with some basic info
their team will contact you to make an
introduction to their preferred agent in
your town and now back to me you know
sometimes reading ads can be tough but
uh getting people to move to florida is
pretty sweet all right so we're going to
talk a little bit about this uh
joe biden guy i was going to call him
brandon this brandon slash joe biden guy
before we start guys if you had to uh
give me one word to sum up the joe biden
presidency what would you say liz you
first one word
does it have to be one word or one
phrase because i think oh dear god is
the best way to describe his presidency
oh dear god all right technically that
was three words but i will accept it
jedediah
yeah i would have said lost in space
that works for me
all right also three words john come on
you're a new yorker i know you can do
this in one word
that's going to go through charm
incapacitated vegetable garden but i'll
just go with dementia
this is what happens when you ask people
who talk for a living to give you one
word okay look everyone knows that this
thing is a disaster it feels like
there's a recession on the way supply
chain gas prices just the whole thing is
just an absolute mess uh but we do have
a black lesbian press secretary that's
the most important thing her name is
corinne jean-pierre and uh peter ducey
who is a rare journalist that i don't
have to put air quotes around uh he
asked her about
inflation and what's going on outside of
our borders as well why is the president
saying that inflation is worse
everywhere but here
because what we have seen
across the globe first of all inflation
is a global challenge as we have said uh
it is uh it is it is
it is caused by uh
clearly
the pandemic this once in a generation
pandemic that we are coming out of and
also uh most recently uh the war that uh
that putin started in ukraine that has
caused inflation as we look at food and
as we look at gas prices so if you look
at globally other countries
and if you look at where we are
economically when you think about the
group 7 the g7 we are in a much stronger
place than we are economically than than
the rest and also i did that globally
though he says that inflation is worse
everywhere but here that's not true the
u.s has worse inflation than germany
france japan canada india italy saudi
arabia so why is he saying
what we are saying is that uh
when you talk about inflation it is a
global thing and it is not just about
the united states this is something that
everyone is feeling because of coming
out of once once in a lifetime pandemic
because of the war that russia has
started in ukraine
so i love her tell there which she does
all the time which is what we are saying
or what we are trying to say it's not
the truth it's just what we are trying
to convey to you uh to hide the truth
mostly uh jedidiah let me start with you
here uh she blames the pandemic remember
kovid that was a thing for a while and
she blames putin of course putin's war
no responsibility these people don't
seem to blame perhaps the printing of
all the money
yeah that was a that was an interesting
moment there he asked her questions
she's like
putin you're just vomiting out we're
pandemic i mean it's a terrible job
listen to have to defend joe biden have
to get up there and lie every day for
joe biden who doesn't even know where he
is half the time not an easy job i'll
give her that the thing is people feel
this stuff so her sitting there and
saying oh inflation you know it's not
really a thing here it's it's more a
thing other places and trying to
invalidate what people's experience is
isn't going to work democrats always
love
to make people feel dumb like oh you're
dumb you don't know what's up they want
you to be dumb they hope you're dumb
because if you're not dumb you're not
going to vote for them but the reality
is that people have to don't people buy
stuff they go to the grocery store they
buy stuff for their kids they see those
prices going up so you're not going to
delude people with a ridiculous answer
like this and suddenly they're going to
say oh well she said it wasn't a big
deal so obviously it's not no that's
like saying oh
gas prices aren't really going up you go
to the gas station you fill up your tank
you have eyes and ears you're not brain
dead they're relying on you to be brain
dead because if you're not brain dead
there is no way in hell that you would
vote for these people so i feel a little
bit bad for her i'm not gonna lie uh not
an easy job but come on man people feel
this stuff own up take some
responsibility for all the stuff you did
this is like saying oh you know this is
their this is their part two dave of oh
if you get the vaccine you won't get
coveted come on
enough with the lies time is up
jedediah i know you were always kind of
red pilled or as long as i've known you
red pill but i think you were like
doubly red-pilled this morning uh liz to
her point do you think anyone is buying
this nonsense i mean i get it we're all
somewhat like-minded so we can see
through this stuff we can explain it
honestly but do you think that anyone is
watching that and not making that
connection between the price at the pump
or when they go to home depot as i was
at yesterday and just buying two by
fours or literally anything that prices
are sometimes double triple if not more
do you think anyone's buying it
no and funny that you mentioned home
depot because literally when we're
sitting here my husband's at home depot
right now and his electronic receipt
just popped into my phone because it's
attached to my email address and the
price is just is astronomical that's the
thing it doesn't matter what your
ideology is when you go to the gas
station and it costs a hundred dollars a
week to fill up uh to fill up your car
to commute back and forth to work to
take your kids to soccer practice or
school it doesn't matter if you're a
republican or democrat the the takeaway
that i got from that video though i get
this like second hand embarrassment for
karine jean-pierre because you know say
what you will about sake she was a lying
hack but at least she was good at it at
least she was skilled at it but karine
jean-pierre is like so relieved when she
can actually regurgitate one of these
answers without checking her binder
first when the answer she's like oh wait
i know that when i actually know the
talking point here um it's a pandemic
and it's putin there i got it um doesn't
matter to her if it's the truth it is of
course false
there's a really interesting
organization called the organization for
economic cooperation and development it
actually is comprised of 37 democracies
around the country and and they compare
around the world i mean they compare
data on their economies to see like if a
trend is happening in germany or in the
united kingdom is it happening here is
this an isolated trend or is it a global
trend and according to this organization
the united states is facing inflation at
two times the rate of the other 30 or
the other 36 nations that are in this
um
in this global cooperation group and so
to blame it on the pandemic and to blame
it on putin makes absolutely no sense
when the pandemic impacted the entire
globe and putin has impacted the entire
globe why would we in the united states
be facing double unless unless dave it
was because of joe biden's policies that
just impact us here so john to that
point even if it was the war and putin
and even if it was the pandemic
and 18 other things that he could excuse
away is it not the job of the president
to respond to things like that well and
make sure that the ship doesn't sink
i mean it would be if he wasn't asleep
in uh delaware in his beach house look
every time which is where he is
tracy chapman of the white house her
identity politics are on the guiding
light of her appointment
all i can think of dave jedediah liz is
that seen in billy madison where the
principal says everyone is dumb for
having to have a listen to the answer
and they treat us like we're idiots look
i paid 6.20
a gallon for premium in boca raton
yesterday that same station was 50 cents
a gallon cheaper last week these are
astronomical
price increases and as jetta diane liz
note people are going to the supermarket
they're going to home depot they're
going to the gas station all the lies in
the world about putin and global
economic conditions
they're not they're not able to sell it
the reality here is that biden
and this is why biden i believe i
tweeted this the other day why when you
hear these reports well biden is
reportedly very frustrated and upset at
his sinking approval ratings i mean
they're boat anchors at this point right
it's because people like susan rice and
barack obama are writing the words biden
is regurgitating but he really doesn't
understand
what he's saying so all these things
fall apart it's disastrous we all know
why again you've got an incapacitated
vegetable in the oval office who sleeps
it off at the beach house america sees
this look i think democrats are in
massive trouble come november we knew it
was going to be a bloodletting
but that special election in texas 34
last week i think dems are terrified
they know they can't sell it they're
trying what they can but really it's
just triage to stop the bleed for 2024
i'm with you guys americans see through
this nonsense yeah i also think you're
making a point that i've tried to bring
up here many times which is it's unclear
whether joe biden knows what he's doing
whether he's being just handed this
stuff and has no clue whether this is
his intention or not et cetera et cetera
by the way as i've said on the show many
times before gas was already up a dollar
fourteen a gallon before putin invaded
russia so let's just be clear about that
uh but the other part that we're all
talking about here is that he's just not
taking any responsibility uh we've got
some video of a guy that you might know
from florida who's all about taking
responsibility
sometimes you know he needs to take
responsibility he's always trying to
blame other people uh he's always trying
to create a scapegoat i guess his
position is that it wasn't until he
became president that oil companies are
trying to make profits like they're
gouging now they weren't doing that for
the last 25 years all of a sudden just
now they're doing that
it's insulting to the average citizen to
listen to some of this drivel coming out
of the white house and because they know
people are upset about it they know
they're responsible for it so they're
just looking for a boogie man uh to try
to pin this on and here's the thing i'm
not going to let them get away with that
okay that's not right
and we're going to hold them accountable
liz obviously i like desantis he's part
of the reason why i moved down to
florida in the first place but isn't it
just refreshing to hear something honest
like hey you're the guy that's in charge
you're supposed to do something about
this because we know that's exactly what
desantis has been doing right here in
florida
yeah it's super refreshing to see
someone like desantis actually take
action um it's also discouraging to see
biden i mean one of the narratives that
they are that the biden administration
is propagating right now is that there's
nothing that biden can do because biden
can't stop a pandemic biden can't stop
putin and since those are the only two
factors causing inflation causing high
gas prices you know what does the
american people expect biden to do it's
not biden's fault this is a lie there
are many policy things that biden can do
immediately that would change the price
of gas that would lower the price of gas
he can drill for oil he can stop
blocking pipelines that bring oil from
canada to the united states he can
actually have stable energy policy so
that the the gas and oil companies who
right now already have federal leases
but aren't actually working on them
because they fear that they will invest
millions maybe even billions of dollars
into this only to have the biden
administration stop them from what
they're doing six months or a year down
the road he can have stable energy
policy he can stop relying on foreign
oil remember we were energy independent
under president trump it was joe biden
who rolled that back and made us
dependent on foreign oil which causes
this this this kind of this this kind of
inflation this kind of rise in gas
prices he can stop sending money abroad
he can stop printing and spending money
that we don't have he can ditch esg
standards um
in companies across the country so that
they don't prioritize this phony idea of
climate change um it that costs the
american people so much money at the
pump of course there's so much that he
can do
um today if he wanted to to stop the
rising gas prices but he chooses not to
liz i love how you just listed off like
27 things and we know that zero of them
are going to happen that's sort of how
this whole thing operates but i want to
shift to the second part of this which
is really about the media because
something interesting is happening here
we all get everyone gets that this thing
is a disaster but the media is starting
to finally talk about it a year and a
half in they're starting to mention the
cognitive stuff they're starting to
blame him for things and believe it or
not it's even making it to cnn
he's in charge at this moment that's
bleak that's right and there's no
question that in some big ways this
administration including the president
and some of his closest economic
advisers got inflation wrong we've heard
that correction from some of his top
officials including the treasury
secretary uh janet yellen saying yeah
last year when we were saying this is
probably going to be temporary and
transitory we were wrong
jedediah you used to be on the view that
is mainstream media and god bless you
for sitting at that table by the way um
it's it's happening i mean it's bursting
forth into the mainstream they cannot
ignore this much longer right
yeah and i survived the view so thank
you for that dave but you know here's
the thing i think that
i think they're setting us all up though
they're going to have to cart somebody
else out here that's not biden listen
i'm sorry he can't do this again he
knows he can't do it again his family
his friends the people close to him know
he can't do this again especially if
he's going to be up against someone like
ron desantis who is the guy to ron we
can get to that in a second but i think
they're setting it up like they're going
to ease in and try to say well joe biden
may have done this wrong they'll turn on
him in two seconds if it means that it's
going to be cackling kamala or it's
going to be somebody else that they pull
out of the woodwork i don't know pete
mayor pete who knows who it's going to
be it could be beto for all we know
where these people are headed but i
think they're going to have to ease us
into that and you're going to see a slow
at first and then quicker transition
where people are going to start to turn
on biden from within the camp because
they know that he cannot get up to the
podium listen in a couple of years he's
not going to be able to get up to the
podium he can't even do it now he phases
out mid-sentence oftentimes it's painful
to watch for all of us and sad and
depressing and people in his family who
are allowing him to do this disgraceful
by the way but i think they're getting
ready to face somebody else in and i
think they're looking at those videos of
desantis listen ron desantis i moved to
florida as well because of desantis he
did everything that was the opposite of
what joe biden did and bill de blasio
did and gavin newsom did and everyone
and their brother sister mother neighbor
moved to florida if he's looking at
desantis and you know they are because
they already started going after it oh
that don't say a gay bill there's no
don't say gay bill they invented that
they did all of that because they're
terrified that a desantis or someone
like him could run and they know damn
well that joe biden cannot hold a candle
to that it's not going to work so
they're starting to think who are we
going to need to push up and i don't
think people should be excited about
this because i'll tell you joe biden is
a conduit for far left policies but what
they're going to be looking at post
biden is someone that's right there
front and center that's your far left
that's someone who's not going to need
to be a conduit because they're going to
want to do it all themselves and i'll
remind you liz talked about all those
things that joe biden could be doing to
make things better of course he could be
doing that leadership starts at the top
the destruction i will remind you is
intentional the destruction is
intentional they need you to be a
dependent they need you to be in poverty
they need you to lose your business
because when you do all of those things
guess who you're dependent on big daddy
government that's what they need those
are the people in society that they one
day get to control get to push a mandate
on and everybody just lays down and does
whatever they want to do so none of this
makes sense until you realize that they
could be doing but they're not doing on
purpose
jedi i said you swallowed a couple extra
red pills before now i'm pretty sure you
snorted them when i was on video with
john a second ago geez she gets it man
uh john to a lot of those points um and
i know you know a ton of insiders in the
swamp and dc area and everything my
feeling is they didn't think that he was
going to break down this quickly i agree
with jedidiah that this is intentional
this is a demolition of of our economy
and our all of our structures and
institutions so that we'll you know sort
of need them more in their estimation
but i don't think that they thought he
wouldn't make it four years and that's
becoming pretty obvious again we're only
a year and a half into this thing with
him
yeah look i mean they deluded themselves
though right guys
think about this we have a corporate
media that set the bar for then
candidate and now president joe biden
his his competency bar was set at oh wow
look he was able to order his own ice
cream chocolate chip i mean this is
where they set the bar for the president
of the united states but to jedidiah's
point i've been saying this for well
over a year year and a half
100 percent she's correct this is all by
design take liz's point about fuel
prices 100
we can open up oil and gas leases we can
increase drilling we've got the refining
capability
to refine as much oil as we bring them
out of the ground as much natural gas we
bring out of the ground but it's very
chilling when the ceo of chevron as he
said the other day says we may never see
another refinery built in the united
states that should kill everybody
but people unfortunately aren't students
of history and if you go back to 2009
1011 when obama was president
again the jedidiah's point about wanting
everybody on the public dole what did
obama do he declared war on the coal
industry we all knew that those were big
headlines the left-wing media loved it
the story they didn't tell is that while
he declared war on the coal industry he
and joe biden increased the output of
the coal leases on bureau of land
management land right so the u.s
government was making billions as they
were destroying private coal producers
they're going to do the same thing here
look i'm going to come out and say it
the democratic party the far left
radical communist democratic party now
wants to do to all americans what
they've done to black americans for
decade upon decade
keep them oppressed keep them in poverty
keep them in squalor and keep them
completely dependent upon government
jedi is right liz is right that is
exactly the end game
there is a theme to this friday show uh
liz before i throw to you let's just
talk a little bit more about the the
cognitive stuff uh because it's again
it's that now it's not just the economic
stuff that's finally leaking to cnn uh
here's cnn's van jones on what's going
on with biden as david axelrod says and
he's come out and put his name on it he
said look this is a person who if they
win will be closer to 90 at the end of
their second term than 80. and therefore
these are very fair questions joe biden
said these were fair questions the last
time when he was running
so do you have these questions
well uh i think everybody is looking
very closely now uh i uh when he does
when biden does well he does really well
that gun speech he gave he was perfect
it was it was powerful when he does
badly when he stumbles you get nervous
and you wonder is it justice stutter is
he tired or something else there and so
i think that people are just looking i
mean honestly i think i think a lot of
democrats are like if if this guy's
ready to go we're behind him but if he's
not ready to go he should let us know i
think that's what
ah i love van jones he uses so many
words to say nothing uh liz
it is leaking into mainstream media i
mean i know you've been talking about it
on your show we've obviously all been
talking about it but once it sort of
breaks that airlock then everyone starts
talking about it right
yes however i would warn conservatives
across the country this is something
that conservatives have been a little
naive about in the past when the
mainstream media finally picks up on
something that we have been talking
about for years or something that's very
obvious to everyday americans don't
don't give the the mainstream media the
benefit of the doubt this does not mean
that they have seen the light this is
not me that they are red pill this does
not mean that their motives are pure
this means that they know that they're
going to get a shellacking in 2022 and
they're already looking for something to
plan of how are we going to explain to
the american people when we lose in in
november we're not we don't want to
blame our policies because we stand by
our policies we don't radical leftists
into the administration into the swamp
into the administrative state so that
they could bring someone like mayor pete
who has a very innocent very very boy
next door look but who's actually very
connected to marxism including the
legacy that was passed down to him by
his father um this is something like i
said conservatives should not fall for
this because this is only a strategy
that's being picked up by the radical
left probably also because they see
polls that show the american people are
concerned about this and they want to
seem like from their high perch from
their elite purchase like they relate to
us yeah i love that point liz because
it's like one of these things every time
these people who get everything wrong
say something remotely not insane we
always fawn over them and it's like no
we've got to stop doing that just
because bill maher is three years late
on everything you got to stop cheering
him on for it until he can get to the
end of the road uh let's listen to joe
biden because he's got more blame game
going now he's blaming texas and florida
and that desantis guy for a bunch of
stuff
no one knows better than the people in
this room we have a lot more work to do
a lot more work to do i don't have to
tell you about the ultra maga agenda
attacking families and our freedoms 300
discriminatory bills introduced in
states across this country in texas
knocking on front doors to harass and
investigate parents who are raising
transgender children in florida going
after mickey mouse for god's sake
that's very close to home
but think about this
going after families knocking on doors
in texas taking transgender children
away going after mickey mouse he's such
a dis i mean this is where it's is it
like is it disingenuous is it buffoonery
does he know what he's reading i mean
the line about mickey mouse which
putting aside the glibness of the joke
it's like no he's going desantis is
going after a massive corporation that
is telling us that they're
indoctrinating children uh that's what
he's actually doing um john i'll go to
you first on this one uh desantis just
has to keep pushing pushing and pushing
right and just let this nonsense be
yeah 100 i mean look you know the
governor full disclosure i know the
governor this is an incredible
incredibly intelligent guy but the
reason that uh uh desantis terrifies the
left dave and i think you'll agree with
me you've uh done your tour with the
with ron you've got to know him very
well and i think jedi and liz have
gotten this just observing him is
desantis has something trump never did
desantis understands
how to dismantle administrative state
institutions and he also understands how
evil they are
and just how damaging they are to the
fabric of america to american
traditionalism to american
exceptionalism this is why ron desantis
terrifies them so he has to absolutely
push on he has to do more of what he's
doing and one of the things i love about
the sadness i've come to learn about him
i know a lot of his staffers this is a
guy who could not care less about a poll
politicians out there they pulled nine
different pollsters whether they should
change their tie from red to blue the
santos will make these sweeping moves so
go after disney in florida and never
once poll it because he knows it's the
right thing to do i think ron gets up
every day ron desantis and he says hey
look what's going to be best for my
constituents my state and the country at
large and really that's the lens through
which he makes his decisions
he's going to continue to throw him off
balance but yeah he needs to continue
right on the same path
you know can i tell you what a real deal
person he is when i had him on the tour
in orlando two weeks ago so i'm sitting
in the green room with him and i my team
walks in and i introduce him to
everybody this is this is conor this is
michael this is phoenix he goes that's
phoenix he's the guy in the book i had
told a story about phoenix who was my
intern at the time and ron the governor
had actually read the book remembered
his name and asked him about it like
that tells you this guy is legit he is
not just pretending he is paying
attention he's reading stuff like it's
real uh i want to show you a headline
from business insider because it gets to
john's point here look at this
desantis is very is a very dangerous
individual because he has already
absorbed all of the lessons of trump but
doesn't have any of the baggage an
expert on fascism argues i love these
fascism experts that they bust out all
the time they're always concerned about
people like us uh but is that the key
point that not only what john said that
he knows how to go in and dismantle this
stuff but he knows how to fight the
media he learned that let's say from
trump uh and he doesn't have say the
personal baggage he's married he's got a
young family all of that jedediah
yeah you know why he's very dangerous
because when someone decides to slap on
a mandate in florida he turns around and
says oh yeah that'll be 28 million
dollars that's what he does he is a man
of action and that's why i was saying
this is his moment because he didn't
just sit back a lot of governors gop
governors sat back and they said oh we
object to what the bidet administration
is doing what did you do about it this
is a guy who went in and he fought mass
mandates he fought you know vax mandates
with policy that protected people in
florida listen i interviewed i was on a
podcast a couple weeks ago the ppd
podcast and i i was just going to
mention it i was going to imagine it
okay listen god bless her you know bless
her heart but she actually came out and
said she's running in florida she came
out and said we should have shut down
florida earlier because then we could
have stopped the spread of covet my head
nearly spun around exorcist style when
she said that because i couldn't believe
that someone was saying that in the
summer of 2022.
not only that everybody moved to florida
because he didn't follow those policies
of lockdown that new york did that
california did all of those places got
buried and it's just pure idiocy
everyone you know got covered backs not
backs they're still getting it it's
everywhere so the idea that you would
have shut down earlier and stop the
spread of cover i mean this is the type
of pure sorry to say but idiotic talking
points that he's battling so this is the
guy at the moment and i think that i
think you're right i think he has a way
of dismantling media he doesn't care
what they say about him he doesn't care
it doesn't keep him up at night he's
like i'm gonna do what i have to do for
the people of florida i don't care what
you write about me he has a good retort
all the time and he gets stuff done i
like governors oftentimes because i say
they have a track record you can look at
what he did in florida and you could say
well magnify that now make him the
leader of the free world and see what
happens all these other governors asleep
at the wheel you better be paying
attention to what he just did this is
the guy i'm telling you man this is his
moment he's the guy to go against joe
biden i don't know if he wants the job i
don't know him personally but if you
guys have his ear man i'd be telling him
go for it there was there was another
beautiful moment in that podcast so
you're sitting next to nicki freed and
she's the she's his main opponent i
guess there's this charlie criss guy too
but they know they're going to get
crushed they have no support they're
complaining while they live in florida
it's so ridiculous but she basically
says to you well he also outlawed a
protest in florida and you're allowed to
drive your car through protesters and
you just looked at her like what the f
are you talk like these people they just
have nothing which leads me to this
question the obvious question is you
were on a panel of four people you were
the only one who is not a floridian how
jelly are you right now
this is this is dave just for everyone
watching this this is dave's ongoing
campaign to get me to move to florida
because i told him that
um that we are considering my husband
and i are considering it and so a
constant onslaught of peer pressure to
get me down there and i mean i got to
tell you it's like this close to working
i i mean i don't know what else i have
to do i don't i really don't know what
else there's nothing i have to do you
just have to come in and enjoy it and
it's not even that humid right now it's
just fine uh let's close on this because
the other thing that's gonna i think
come over the next couple months is that
the media is gonna really try to set up
some sort of fight between trump and
desantis now i have no idea what
desantis wants to do i i did spend some
about 20 minutes with him solo before
the event i didn't even ask i didn't
think it was appropriate and i know how
much he loves florida and he's got a
race here but that is where the media
clearly is going to go with this because
they would love to have these two take
each other out what do you guys think
has to happen so that does not happen
john you first
i think i think desantis is far too
smart to take that bait uh trump might
but i don't think the santas will at
least he's a strategic guy
i think it's incumbent upon those of us
in in conservative media conservative
commentary to push back on that not pick
sides too easy don't give the left the
sound bites and fodder they want but
again it all comes down to the
individuals and
not to be redundant i think the sound is
too smart too strategic to take debate
jedediah what do you think as a
floridian we got a good governor and a
guy that's most likely gonna who's up in
mar-a-lago right now probably plotting
and i think probably in the next month
going to make the move
i think they just i think i heard you
say this i'm not 100 sure but just sit
behind the scenes the two of you go get
a lunch
go get a good lunch sit down talk it
through don't let that stuff leak out
figure out what's going on amongst
yourself be good with it you know be
comfortable with it and then that's it
because you can't you can't split that
group right you have people who are avid
trump supporters you have people who
love desantis they need to fuse together
let me say this no matter who it is i
don't care if it's trump i don't care if
it's desantis i don't think you're going
to have people this round that are like
oh i don't like trump's personality so
i'm going to vote the other one no
there's too much at stake now people are
thinking about their kids they're
looking at mass mandates they're looking
at vast mandates people lost their jobs
you're looking at freedom disappearing
in the united states of america i don't
think it's going to be a moment where
people are worried about tweets or
worried about personality things have
gotten too crazy and too big too fast so
i'm not worried that if it's desantis oh
these trump supporters aren't going to
vote or if it's trump i'm not worried
about that anymore but i do think avoid
the media narrative don't give them any
steam settle it amongst yourselves come
out it is what it is end of story no
drama for the record i want to be very
clear about this i would vote for the
old bones of ronald reagan if they dug
them up instead of joe biden um but yes
jedidiah that's what i said on newsmax
the other day that they just need to
imagine if they just have a sit down
they just have a sit down amongst
themselves we don't even need to know
what the negotiations are exactly what's
going on and they imagine if they do
that and then they sort of come out as a
unified front regardless of who's top of
the ticket or whether someone's running
or not running
um and they they just say hey we've
settled this stuff and we're both moving
forward whatever that means it's like
it's pretty unstoppable what do you
think liz
yeah i think i think what you said is
correct that um that republicans
conservatives across the country maybe
even some democrats here they're going
to vote for whoever the republican
candidate is it's not going to be it's
not going to be a divided a divided
republican party when it's when it's up
against either joe biden or joe biden's
radical leftist successor here i i of
course echo this idea that this this
between trump and desantis their
conversation shouldn't be hashed out in
the media it's fine if you and i and the
rest of us jedidiah john and everyone
else talk about this but their
conversations should be should be had
behind closed doors because there's a
world where there's some kind of joining
forces that becomes really powerful
there are a lot of voters in the
conservative movement who think that
trump was a good president especially
the first three years of his presidency
and then they didn't really like what he
did with kovid they didn't really like
how he handled election integrity even
though they share his concerns about
election integrity and and they're ready
for him to pass the torch to desantis at
the same time but they don't want it to
blow up in the media they don't they
don't want it to be this big division
that the radical left takes advantage of
so yeah i would encourage the same thing
i mean sit down hash this out a lot of
people are are ready to have torch pass
but appreciate president trump's legacy
where it stands
as i often say we just have to be a
little bit better than these people and
it ain't that hard because they're
pretty pretty terrible
john jedediah liz thank you very much
have a great weekend guys i'll
definitely have you back on and jedidiah
i got to tell you when when did you get
to florida how long ago
uh it's just been about a month it is
clearly clearly working for i love john
john you've been here for what 20 years
already
18 february was 18 years yeah when you
see people like me a few months ago you
saw me right when i got here and you see
jed and i get here and you see that like
renewed energy and passion for life is
that is that old for you yet or do you
still revel in that
no so jedediah and i had a couple of
phone calls or a text and before she
moved down talking about areas and you
could even you could sense the
excitement through the texts when i was
talking to her liz we got to get you
guys down here as well come taste the
freedom liz come taste the freedom
as soon as it gets cold here in the
northeast i think you're gonna you're
gonna see me you're gonna see me sneak
in
i could sense liz was texting her
husband under the table over there
all right i'm going to finish up guys
but have a great weekend and i hope to
see you guys in person soon
thanks thanks dave
all right everybody uh you see what i'm
talking about there is some momentum the
obvious truths are bursting forth you
can't hide truth for that long you can't
lie about everything all the time even
when you've got the entire machine
enough good people can see the truth and
i think that really was the theme today
yes things are banged up there bad yes
like the economy really is screwy and it
probably is going to get worse and house
prices are going to go through these
crazy fluctuations now and we know about
interest rates and gas prices it's all
true it's true all of it right but that
doesn't mean that there isn't goodness
on the other side and maybe
i don't know exactly what rock bottom is
in a way right and things things can
always be a hell of a lot worse i'm not
going to sit in america even despite all
this nonsense in 2022 and tell you we're
close to rock bottom but the point is
things can get to a breaking point where
enough people will suddenly be like okay
as much as they've tried to scare me i
do remember a couple years ago and i do
remember when the economy was good and i
do remember when we weren't in this
nonsensical war and i do remember when
the administration wasn't lying to us
about everything all the time so that is
exactly why i'm hopeful i'm also hopeful
because today's a big day around here
because we just released my first ever
stand stand-up special it is a 40-minute
special no edits taped live on location
in orlando during that show that i did
with governor ron desantis and i think
we updated the trailer slightly let's
show you that right now
perhaps maybe
ladies and gentlemen please welcome host
of the reuben report author of don't
burn this country and new floridian dave
rubin
so they're out there and if you saw
these people they're they're chanting
they're literally chanting we
say
gay
at my show
i don't just say it i mean i'm doing it
you know what i mean
disney has lost 41
billion dollars
donald duck
is wandering the streets of orlando
sucking dick for a hot lunch
how many of you are conservatives
okay conservatives that basically means
you have a job
so
good for you guys that's very very mean
and very scary
ben shapiro is four foot six okay
he's actually in my pocket right now
you guys want to see him
[Music]
[Applause]
all right there's a little teaser for
you that is my very first stand-up
special it's 40 minutes chock full o
laughs laughs guaranteed i don't even
have to put an asterisk next to that i
promise you we'll laugh you can get it
right now we are launching it
exclusively through my locals community
so it is free for all annual subscribers
so you can go to reubenreport.locals.com
and if you're an annual subscriber you
also get two months free and then the
special is absolutely free or it is
available for one time purchase for
9.99
and if you're a member of the military
or you're struggling otherwise because
of finances let's see if we can help you
out just message us on the community and
we'll see what we can do it's not about
breaking the bank with this thing and i
want people to see it obviously and i
know things are a little upside down but
right now you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com as i said if you
are an annual subscriber you get two
months free you get the special or the
special is available one time purchase
for
9.99 there are jokes about ben shapiro
there are jokes about jen saki there are
jokes about donald trump there are jokes
about ron desantis there are jokes about
all of the people that we talk about on
this show and it's good-natured and it's
fun and it's politically incorrect and
it's non-woke and all of that good stuff
on that note people i have literally 50
people in and outside my house doing
work on a million things and thanks to
brandon you can't get screws you can't
get windows i'm doing work myself i
gotta get going have a great weekend
everybody see you monday